Hey Crazies.
There this thing that mathematicians and physicists
like to say:
Math is the language of the universe.
You’ve probably heard it so many times that
you’ve just accepted it as truth.
But rule #8 here at the Science Asylum is
Question Everything?
Is math really the language of the universe?
Answering this question is going to take some
time and we need to be careful,
so let’s start with a simpler question:
Is math even a language?
What is a language, anyway?
That’s two questions, but I’ll see what
I can do.
We need to know what a language is before
we can decide if math is one.
A Language is a complex system of words and
symbols, either spoken or written, used by
a particular community as a means of communication.
OK, so it makes sense why something like English,
German, Arabic,
or even iglatin pay would be languages.
But what about math?
Is math a complex system of words and symbols?
Yes!
Either spoken or written?
Mostly written, but yes!
Is it used by a particular community?
Definitely, yes!
As a means of communication?
Well… maybe?
The purpose of math isn’t just to communicate
ideas to each other.
Math is used as a tool to make predictions
about the actual world.
Of course, this requires us to also ask:
Is the sole purpose of a language to communicate?
I would say no… and I think most of you
would agree with me.
Language can also be used a tool.
In the right hands, language can be used to
inspire, to lightening the mood,
or to strengthen someone’s resolve.
In the wrong hands, it can be used to hurt
someone, to destroy their reputation,
instill fear, or even to control others.
I don’t think the fact that math is used
as a tool is a disqualifier.
The definition of a language doesn’t even
require that communication be the sole purpose.
It said “as a means of” not “for the
purpose of”
I’m still not entirely convinced though.
We need another test.
Something else we know about languages is
that you can translate between them,
so, if we can translate between math and a
language like English,
then we might have a decent argument.
Oh! You want start an argument? Well, let me tell you...
No, not that kind of argument.
When I say “Argument,” I don’t mean
one of those fights over politics or whatever.
An argument is more of a set of reasons or
ideas in support of a conclusion
in an effort to persuade others to the same
conclusion.
It’s a point made by a logical individual
in a calm discussion.
People are rarely thinking logically in political
conversations.
Anyway, let’s give translation a try.
When you translate from any language to another,
some meanings can get lost,
but as long as most ideas can translate, I
think we’re good.
We said earlier that languages are made of
words and symbols
and that math has plenty of symbols.
The most recognizable symbol is probably this
one: the equal sign.
The word “equal” is more of a name than
a meaning though.
A direct translation for the equal sign would
be “is the same as”
which is a phrase rather than a word, but
that’s OK.
Translations don’t have to be a one-word-to-one-word
correspondence.
This English 8-word sentence is 6 words in
Polish, but 10 words in Albanian.
Math is just much more concise.
It takes way fewer symbols to contain a meaning.
Except you don’t find a mathematics option
in Google Translate
So what gives?
Is it a language or not?
Hmm, I don’t think we can judge by Google
Translate.
It only has 103 languages
and there are over 6900 spoken languages currently
in use,
not to mention all the dead languages.
My point is that Google Translate is far from
complete,
so let’s try some translations on our own.
Math uses the Latin letters and the Greek
letters
both upper case and lower case
and a whole collection of other unique symbols;
which is probably why people are so afraid
of it.
All of those symbols have at least one meaning,
but many have multiple meanings that we have
to understand by context.
For example, an upper case “B” could be
the bulk elastic constant,
which represents how rigid something is in
response to pressure changes.
Like air in response to a sound wave passing
through it.
But an upper case “B” could also be the
strength of a magnetic field
the kind of thing you might imagine is around
a bar magnet.
This is pretty typical of languages though.
Take the English word “Duck,” for example.
It could refer to a type of bird
or the action of suddenly lowering your head.
Words with multiple meanings are so common
there’s a word to describe them: Homonym,
so multiple meanings doesn’t disqualify
math as a language either.
Let’s try to translate a whole sentence.
Say you’ve got a simple mathematical sentence
like this.
It makes use of 6 symbols: Delta, s, Equals,
f, i, and minus.
We’ve already seen Equals means “is the
same as.”
Delta means “change in” and S means “position”
or “where something is.”
The “f” and “i” are only subscripts.
They just describe the symbol they’re attached
to,
so they’re more like adjectives than nouns.
“f” stands for “final” or “at the
end,”
“i” stands for “initial” or “at
the beginning,”
and minus means “the difference between.”
So this mathematical sentence reads: “The
change in where something is is the same as
the difference between where that something
is at the end and where that something is
at the beginning.”
Seems like a pretty logical statement.
You can do this with other mathematical sentences
too.
Newton’s 2nd Law, Ohm’s Law, even Einstein’s
Equation.
Like any other translation though, you lose
some meaning.
Mathematical sentences say a lot more than
their English translation.
You’re also going to have a really hard
time translating the other way.
This English sentence has no translation in
Math.
Although, I’m willing to hear arguments
in favor of this one.
Translations, Grammar, Adjectives, and Nouns.
Sounds a lot like a language to me.
And, as a scientist, I use it to communicate
with people all the time.
So is math a language?
I would argue “yes”
and, just like any other language, it’s
governed by a set of rules.
Those rules are just a lot more absolute than
a typical language
and they’re built from the ground up.
This gives math some extra power if you know
how to use it,
which brings us back to our original question:
Is math really the language of the universe?
OK, this one is a little trickier.
If math really is the language of the universe,
then anything we calculate should have meaning,
which seems to be true of counting.
We take something like this and call it “one.”
and something like this and call it “two.”
We can put them together and call that “three.”
We can put three of those threes together
and call it “nine”
These seem like pretty solid rules
and they seem to apply to the universe.
But we’re going to learn a lot more if we
try to disprove it.
We need to find a number that doesn’t have
any meaning.
Hmm, there are tons of calculations I could
just make up,
but no one would ever expect those to have
meaning anyway.
Maybe something people would expect to have
meaning.
What about density?
Oh! That’s brilliant!
I’m so glad you’re a clone of me.
Density measures the “compactness” of
a substance.
An easy way to calculate it is take the mass
and divide by the volume
and this tells you something about the spacing
between the molecules.
It makes sense for things like ice or rubber
or helium gas or air
Wait a minute!
Density measures the “compactness” of
a substance.
Air is a mixture of a bunch of different things.
Mostly Nitrogen and Oxygen gas, but still a
mixture.
It’s a pretty uniform mixture though, so
I could understand
arguments for calling that mixture one
substance.
But what about this?
Can’t I just measure mass on scale
and the volume using a beaker
and then divide the two numbers?
I suppose you could, but that number wouldn’t
really say anything.
It’s what we’d call an average density,
which might make sense for a uniform mixture
like air.
But not for this rubber ducky.
It’s made of two substances: rubber and
air.
and they’re definitely not uniform throughout
the ducky.
So, while it might be a useful short-cut in
a calculation somewhere,
it doesn’t actually tell you anything about
the compactness of the ducky.
It’s a number that only exists on paper.
It has no physical meaning
and that’s another reason it can’t be
used to explain why things float,
commenters!!
Anyway, all average values sit in this grey
area.
Sometimes they have meaning and sometimes
they don’t.
Meaning is what we’re looking for in science.
We’re trying to answer deep philosophical
questions about our existence like:
Where did we come from?
Why are we here?
Science is about meaning.
It’s about language.
Plus there are plenty of statements that have
meaning,
but don’t have a translation into math.
Math alone will never be enough.
No number will ever answer those deep philosophical
questions.
Not even 42!
Math is not the language of the universe.
Even if we wanted to personify the universe
and say it’s trying to communicate with
a language,
which I would advise against,
Math is only a small part of our best translation
of it.
So, what do you think?
Does the universe work using math?
Or is it something we made up?
I’d like to know in the comments.
Thanks for liking and sharing this video…
Don’t forget to subscribe if you'd like to keep up with us.
And until next time, remember, it’s OK to
be a little crazy.
In the last video, we learned about the lives
of stars.
Comment response time!
Benbedra mentioned you can learn a lot more
from star light than just color and age.
Yes, using optics, we can also learn what
the star is made of
and how fast it’s moving toward or away
from us.
You can also get distance sometimes,
but that’s a topic for another video.
Ira Sanborn told his kids the light coming
from the Sun peaks in green!
It’s pretty weird, but it’s true.
In fact, it’s very common for stars.
If you take all the peak wavelengths from
all the stars in the universe,
you get a greenish color.
It just doesn’t look green because it’s
emitting the other colors too.
When our eyes receive light of all colors,
it sends that information to the brain,
but that just looks like a jumbled mess,
so your brain turns it all white to create
contrast in your field-of-view.
Yeah, white light is an illusion.
Also a topic for another video.
Miss Physics wished she had studied more
astrophysics in her undergrad.
The downside to university programs
is really all the non-majors courses you have to
take to get a degree.
Undergrad took me 5 years and I still didn’t get
to take all the undegrad physics courses I should have.
I guess we’ll just have to learn things
on our own.
It’s more fun that way anyway. School's intense.
Graeme Wilson asked if black holes were frozen
at absolute zero
and the answer is “no.”
For a while, we had special laws for black
holes,
but eventually realized they were just the
laws of thermodynamics.
Black holes have to obey the laws of thermodynamics
just like anything else.
Even though that might result in a few paradoxes.
Future video.
I agree completely with Jim Groth that how
we know what we know is very important.
Getting to see the process can make science
feel more doable to non-scientists.
And learning the history behind it can help us
understand the obstacles we ran into along the way,
which is why my advanced eBook is written
from a historical perspective.
Because even people who go into physics like
me need that history.
Keadin Mode Star Trek is the best the
reason to talk about Wolf 359!
A close second would be that it’s so low-mass,
it almost isn’t a star.
Future video.
OK, one more thing before I go:
YouTube has started these end-card annotations
that work on mobile,
but there’s a 20 second limit, which means
I can’t use them.
These comment responses are a few minutes
long.
I’m considering separating comment-responses
into their own video,
kind of like how Idea Channel does it,
but I didn’t want to do that without talking
to you first.
Pros: It lets me use the mobile annotations
and it makes the videos a little more sharable.
Con: It separates the conversation, which
I’m a really hesitant about.
Let me know you thoughts or feelings about
this in the comments.
OK crazies, thanks for watching
and I’ll see you next time.